she re-tweeted this meme
of a life of a philosopher in a nutshell
it's birth and death and in between it's
a chubby guy and says why though
um
what do you think is the answer to that
well the answer is that everything that
can exist might exist and in many ways
you take an ecological perspective the
same way as when you look at human
opinions and cultures it's not that
there is right and wrong opinions uh
when you look at this from this
ecological perspective but every opinion
that fits between two human years might
be between two human years and
so when I see in a strange opinion on
social media it's not that I feel that I
have a need to get upset it's often more
that a oh there you are and an opinion
is incentivized then it's going to be
abundant and this when you take this
ecological perspective also on yourself
and you realize you're just one of these
mushrooms that are popping up and doing
their thing and you can depending on
where you chose to grow and where you
happen to grow you can flourish or not
doing this or that strategy and it's
still all the same life at some level
it's all the same experience of being a
conscious being in the world and you do
have some choice about
we want to be more than any other animal
has that to me is fascinating and so I
think that rather than asking yourself
what is the one way to be
um think about what are the
possibilities that I have what would be
the most interesting way to be that I
can be because everything is possible so
you get to explore this not everything
is possible but if things fail most
things Fair
but uh often there are possibilities
that we are not seeing especially if we
choose who we are
to the degree we can choose
Yasha you're one of my favorite humans
in this world Consciousness is to merge
with for a brief moment of time it's
always an honor it always blows my mind
it will take me days if not weeks to
recover
I and I already miss our chats
um thank you so much thank you so much
for uh speaking with me so many times
thank you so much for all the ideas you
put out into the world and
um I'm a huge fan of following you now
in this interesting weird time but going
through with AI
so uh thank you again for talking today
thank you Alex for this conversation I
enjoyed it very much